hello everybody uh as Sarah said I'll be
uh I'm Emily Hoppa at JW plant and I'll
be talking to you today about how we are
tuning the models that power our video
and Marketplace using feedback loops
um so first what is JW player uh we are
an online video platform which means
that we help power the video for
thousands of leading Publishers and
broadcasters who are playing uh video on
the web or on aut devices for example
um and we're actually the number one
solicit video views on the open web
uh so we are using this big scale to
build data products that really are
helping our customers to succeed so to
give you a few examples we have a
recommendations engine that surfaces
interesting and relevant videos to uh
the end viewers
um to keep them watching we have an
article matching product that helps our
customers identify the content in their
media libraries that um matches the
articles that they've written based on
uh the the metadata of a given page
and we have a video ad targeting product
which is what I'll be focusing on today
and what this does is it tries to
identify really high quality ad spots
and connect those with advertisers who
are prepared to pay more money for them
so why why is advertising interesting
well uh it pays the bills um a lot of
our content producers are monetizing
their content using ad Impressions we
have hundreds of millions of video plays
daily accompanied by hundreds of
millions of AD Impressions every day
um and so that means we've got this
really
um interesting uh view on the video ads
played on the web where we've got a lot
of diverse uh content producers with
these ad spots and we can use that pool
to match up really closely with what
advertisers who we work with want for
their campaigns
uh in order to understand this I'm
afraid we'll have to uh understand a
little bit about how video ad auctions
work I promise I will keep this brief
um so first uh video loads on our page
and this means that we know an ad spot
has become available so we send out bid
requests for this ad spot to the
advertising Marketplace
they will send bids back and whichever
bid wins can place an ad against this
media
now the advertisers will have told the
partners their Partners in the
advertising Marketplace which kind of AD
spot they're actually interested in
placing ads in this is known as ad
targeting and it will inform which bids
and for how much the advertising
Marketplace is making
ad auctions also happen in uh can also
happen through the JW player Marketplace
um and that means that we can make use
of the additional information we have on
what's going on as the video player
um to uh identify better
um add spots so uh all of the bid
requests that are coming from all of our
media with all of their various
potential ad spots uh come to us and we
decide whether to uh pass them as
targeted bid requests to the advertising
Marketplace so that means that we think
that this particular ad spot is going to
match up to the requirements um the
targeting of a particular advertising
campaign we're working with
and we'll send the others anything that
doesn't match that targeting as a plain
old bid request
now of course we're still going to get
bids back from these other bid requests
but we hope that we're going to get
higher bids back on the targeting bid
requests because the advertisers have
this guaranteed quality of these ad
spots
um so what is an advertise actually
looking for in this targeting
there's really two main Dimensions that
they're working across and one is the
context of the video
um and I should be clear I'm talking
about the context of the video not for
example the um demographic
characteristics of the end user we don't
uh deal with anything like that so this
might actually be something like the
geographic location
um the the uh what the content of the
video is and this is really important
because as an Advertiser I only want to
place ads in front of people who might
buy my product so if I'm a company that
sells gardening supplies in Canada then
the people who I think are going to buy
my product are the ones who are based in
Canada and they might be more interested
in it if they're the kind of people who
are watching Home and Garden videos I
also maybe want to be sure that this
video is brand safe that I'm not going
to tarnish my Brand's reputation by
having my ad play just before it
um all of this information is known as
soon as the video player is embedded on
the page
um so we can very confidently say to the
advertiser yes this picks all of your
boxes we think this is going to be a
great place for your ad
however advertisers also want to Target
specific performance goals so that is
how much is the um end viewer engaging
with the ad is the ad actually visible
to them while it's playing is the ad
going to be completed by the viewer and
this of course is not known until the ad
actually plays what we can do is predict
um how we think the ad is going to uh
perform
so let's get started from uh where this
project with the feedback loop started
off
um so uh our models are kind of based on
two main uh types of data one is
historical
um and to explain this let's think about
ad completion rate so we have this ad
for milk and The Advertiser has a
hypothesis that if the viewer is
watching this add to completion they're
much more likely to buy the product so
they say they want 70 of these um ads to
be watched to completion in order to pay
a good price for it
um now we have a hypothesis that the
thing driving this ad completion rate is
actually the quality of the media that
it is being placed against so if the
media is really interesting people are
actually going to make it through the
whole ad because they really want to
watch the video at the end of it
so for example this media might have a
93 of the ads placed against it uh
historically might be completed because
everybody's super psyched to find out
what's happening with these cows
and this will be different from media to
Media with the media itself being the
causal Factor so you can see for example
this media um is presumably pretty
boring is only a set of people actually
make it through the ad against this
media
so we make a model that says the
probability that an Advil can be
completed on a given media is equal to
the historical ad completion rate
against that media the uh passes the key
to the present
but can we do any better than that
so we said against this media only a set
of ads are going to get completed
um and
but can we know if this particular ad
spot against this particular player of
this media is going to be one of that 30
percent
um well we can get pretty close to this
using real-time signals available to us
uniquely through our player
um to predict the specific ad spots that
we think are likely to be completed
um using a logistic regression model
so out of these nine potential plays of
this media with nine potential ad spots
we're hoping to pick out the three
um that are going to be completed
or to identify those
so I've been talking about probability
so far but what we actually want is a
binary do we send this ad spot as a
targeted ad spot to The Advertiser or
not and to convert those we're going to
use a heuristic where we set the
decision threshold of our model to the
desired performance so that means if I'm
a company that is targeting a 70 AD
completion rate we're only going to flag
the ad spots that are on media with at
least 70 historical ad completion rate
so these two cycle in red for example
and at the ad spot level with at least a
70 predicted probability of that
particular ad being completed
of course there's no free lunch there is
a trade-off and that is that the uh
better we want these ads that we're
passing to perform the fewer ads we can
pass so here I'm showing
um for a bunch of our for our media
um what the historical ad completion
rate is so you can see that a bunch of
our media have pretty high ad completion
and then there's another uh cluster
around this level of that completion
rate historically
um and if we're using that historical ad
completion rate as a threshold then this
is the number of AD spots that are
possibly available to us uh just
filtering on that so you can see that as
we increase that threshold we massively
drop off the number of AD spots
available especially at these much
higher at completion rates
so I said we were setting the decision
threshold equal to the desired
performance so say this is our desired
performance from this dashed line then
we'll have this many ad spots available
to us however as you've probably seen
this is not the best we can do if we're
integrating over all of these media that
are above this threshold we're actually
going to overshoot the ad campaign goal
up here in this staff
and what we want to do is to exactly
match that campaign goal which and to do
that then we can set a much lower
threshold and we can really increase the
number of AD spots that are available to
us
um and it turns out advertisers really
only care about meeting not exceeding
their performance goals and they care
much more about the number of ads they
can put in front of people so they care
about this number of AD spots or the
reach of their campaign
so this is where the feedback loops come
in
um
so let's just go over feedbacks really
feedback loops really quickly
uh say we have some system it's going to
have some inputs it's going to have some
outputs and hopefully we're monitoring
those outputs
um and we can use uh observation of the
output of our system to adjust the
inputs
um now typically we might actually have
a Target which is what we want which we
use to inform the settings which are the
things we can actually change about the
in-person system and we use the
difference between what we observe of
the outputs and what our Target is to
make adjustments to those settings
so an example you may be pretty familiar
with is cruise control and in this case
the target would be the set speed of um
the speed you've set for your car uh the
output would be the actual speed you're
going and the setting is going to be how
to press that accelerator pedal is and
by monitoring your actual speed then
your car knows whether it needs to uh
your actual speed relative to the set
speed then your condos whether it needs
to uh pull off the gas or not
in the context of the JW player
Marketplace uh it looks pretty similar
um so we start off with an ad campaign's
ad completion goal this informs the
decision threshold of uh models um as I
said we start off with that heuristic
that these two are the same
it goes into these models which are
designing which ad spots to pass to an
ad campaign and spits out the ad spots
that are going to be passed with the
targeting and then we can measure the
performance of the ad spots we send out
with tagding and use that to feed back
in to this decision threshold based on
how different that is to our ad
campaigns actual ad completion goal
um so this is an example of one of our
feedback loops uh that is uh in Flight
um so this dashed line here is showing
the target performance the target at
completion rate for a particular ad
campaign and the red line is showing how
those ad slots that we that we uh that
we passed are performing uh are
performing
um and we can look at this as relative
so what is the difference between the ad
performance and uh and the and the goal
here
thank you and uh what's happening is
that we look at this difference and we
change the decision threshold on our
model based on how it's doing so here
you can see that we're over performing
uh goal with these red bars here so this
blue dot shows how we change the
decision threshold in response to that
so it's going down and down and then we
have this kind of wacky day where we do
really badly so we shoot that decision
threshold back up again but then of
course now we're massively over
performing so we shoot that back down
again and then it stays pretty stable
over here
so again here the target is our ad
completion rate as set by the campaign
the output is the ad completion rate of
the ad spots that we're passing to their
campaign and the thing that we're
actually able to change about our system
is how strict the decision threshold is
I should say uh this is a feedback loop
for one particular campaign we actually
have thousands of these in Flight
um which are individually tuning models
each of our models for each of our
campaigns
and what does this actually do for us
well it now means we can really
precisely we can much more precisely
control the performance of the ad spots
that we're passing to our advertisers so
you can see here in purple I'm showing
what the performance would have been
without the feedback loops and in
general we're outperforming the
campaign's goals by as much as 10 to 15
often
in this uh red hump that's the
performance of uh campaigns with a
feedback loop active and you can see
it's really tight pretty tightly
centered close to zero where zero would
be absolutely Optimum matching our
campaign's goals
and more significantly this means that
we massively increase the number of AD
spots that we're passing to our
Advertiser so you can see here that we
get almost two times as many ad spots
um using this feedback loop because
we're able able to dynamically adjust
that decision threshold and uh match the
performance that our advertisers
actually want
uh and this becomes even more dramatic
if you uh look at it in terms of uh how
strict the campaign's performance goal
is
um so the stricter uh the campaign the
the more significant this effect is with
this
um again like two-fold increase for this
producer campaign uh these strict pretty
strict campaigns up here
now unfortunately uh model output is not
the same as reality
um
so this graphic I showed to you before
this is what an ad auction looks like
using the JW player Marketplace but how
I should have looked is there's a big
back black box over the advertising
Marketplace outside of JW player we do
not have a ton of oversight uh into
what's going on here and in fact it can
often be pretty different from what we
suggest to the the the the spots that
we're passing to the advertising
Marketplace and that's because the
advertisers may not be bidding on all of
the spots that we pass them but they
also may not be winning every auction
that they're bidding on and so
um this is kind of a big question mark
that we also can't monitor very
carefully because we uh it's outside of
our ecosystem
and what this leads to is discrepancies
between the model output and reality so
let's take it as given that the feedback
loops I've already talked about are
doing a stellar job the um the ad spots
that we're passing to the advertising
Marketplace are
um exactly hitting that goal so zero on
this graph uh is exactly hitting the
goal
um this is uh and then we're showing the
difference of the performance of the ads
actually placed by the campaign versus
the performance of the ads that we are
passing them and so here the campaign
for whatever reason is happening to
place ads on uh ad spots that are more
likely to be completed
um and then over here as it's
undershooting then uh the ads that it's
actually placing on ad spots that are
less likely to be completed relative to
the ones that we're actually passing
them
foreign
you might think uh okay well this is the
feedback loop you talked about and
there's an easy fix here this thing that
we're measuring is the performance of
the ad spots that we're passing but
clearly what the campaign cares about is
the ads that they're actually placing
right so
surely we can take uh these are the
targeted ad spots those feed into the
ads placed by the campaign and then we
can measure the performance of the
campaign's ads and use that
um discrepancy to feedback into the
decision threshold
however as I said
this which ads are placed as kind of a
big black box there's a lot of factors
going on here that we don't have
oversight into uh insight into
um and we don't have control over
and so
um trying to do a feedback loop like
this uh is much more difficult uh and we
worried that this might be prone to
instabilities
um and so we didn't want to we didn't
want to do this instead we set up this
Cascade of uh feedback loops so here is
that same feedback loop diagram that you
know and love by now uh but we have this
other feedback loop that is sitting on
top of it so here we start with the ad
campaign stated at completion goal
um uh that feeds into the ad Marketplace
and uh says which ads uh controls partly
which ads are going to be placed by the
campaign
and we can measure the performance of
that of those campaign ads that adds
placed by that campaign
and then we can use the discrepancy
between that measured performance and
the stated performance to create an
adjusted ad completion goal and then
this is what feeds into our inner
feedback loop
and we close the circle because uh due
to our adjusted completion goal
um the decision threshold is going to
change so which ad spots we're sending
out targeting for is going to change and
we hope that uh the ad spots we're
sending out targeting on is going to
play a big role in uh deciding which uh
ads are actually end up being placed by
the campaign
um so this is still in progress to build
this Cascade of PID control of feedback
loops
um and there is an algelea uh where the
target again is the ad completion rate
goal set by the campaign and the output
is the ad completion rate of ads that
are actually placed by the campaign
where as we already discussed that can
be discrepancies depending on what the
campaign uh decides to bid on oil
actually succeeds in winning the
auctions off
so here I'm showing uh similar graphs to
what we are looking at before
um but this time the output of our
feedback loop is
um the performance goal the adjusted
performance goal so ad completion uh
golf
and you can see that as the campaign
continues to outperform uh what we want
then we uh the the performance goal that
we're aiming for tags and tanks and
tanks and tanks until this point where
suddenly our campaign starts
underperforming and then it rises back
up and studies out and you can see as
well when it goes back to what we expect
that actually requires another
adjustment because the beauty of these
feedback loops is they adjust to
whatever the world looks like at the
moment right there isn't this like
preconceived notion of zero being
important
so the settings that we're able to alter
here are the adjusted performance goal
and we use that as the uh
Target for our inner layer now so now
this black dashed line which was
previously flat that single performance
goal set by the campaign looks like the
adjusted performance campaign uh goal
output by a previous feedback loop and
you can see that um we are uh with the
buzz
um there's some discrepancy in the
simulation between uh the goal and
reality and that is also playing into
the decision threshold I should say this
looks a bit odd because what you can see
here is that as the performance goal is
tanking we actually hit a decision
threshold in the simulation of zero um
so this is a base rate performance uh
across our Network for example
so
to conclude
um the marketplace that we've built a JW
player benefits both advertisers and
publishes so the advertisers are able to
make use of a unique Data Insights to
Target the specific ad spots
um which are watched by the right people
in the right places
um
uh uh both by context and also by how
engaged we think the audience is going
to be
the Publishers in turn are getting much
more ad Revenue because advertisers are
willing to pay more money in order to
get this guaranteed quality of AD spot
and JW player is making it all happen
maximizing the number of high quality ad
Impressions that are available by using
our feedback loops in combination with
the real-time and historic models that
we uh use to power all of our decisions
so thank you very much and I would love
to take any questions
thank you Emily for this interesting
talk and we're
happy to answer any questions
Brad
you're back I'm back I pressed a button
okay
um
yes we do have a question
um yeah so this is actually a batch
processed
um
in order for a feedback loop the way
that our feedback loops work it assumes
a discrete uh uh time interval so you
have some time interval you measure what
happens and the discrepancy over that
time interval depending on how long that
time interval is you weight the
difference accordingly
um and so in that way it's batch
um but we are making the uh the
real-time predictions for example those
are based obviously on observations that
we're getting in real time so those are
happening at the instant before the bid
requests are sent out
um but the adjustment to the decision
threshold is done in a batch basis
okay I think there are no more questions
and we would like to thank you very much
for your time
and thank you for the very interesting
talk
thanks very much for having me uh really
appreciate it and enjoy the rest of your
day everybody
bye